pretty disturbing news to start the week
with we can now confirm that the former
president had a meeting with
anti-semites people who have made
extremely offensive comments about the
Holocaust and about the Jewish people as
a whole
now that meeting did not happen over the
weekend it actually happened back in
2005 when then Senators soon to be
presidential candidate Barack Obama and
the Congressional Black Caucus met for
smiles and giggles and photographs with
Louis Farrakhan who calls the Jews
termites and the media covered it up and
told everybody that it wasn't a big deal
uh the former president's meeting with
the prominent anti-semites was not
confined to one night it actually took
place over the course of two decades
when Barack Obama was a registered
member of the church of his good friend
Jeremiah Wright until in Wright's words
quote them Jews stopped letting him talk
to me and then two the media pretty much
brushed the whole thing under the rug
and Obama never had to apologize and
everybody just moved on
oh also Donald Trump had dinner with his
troubled friend of many years Kanye West
over the weekend which according to the
media is an unforgivable sin and makes
Trump the second coming of Hitler which
the same media of course have already
been claiming ceaselessly about Donald
Trump for the past seven years I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on what was it Wednesday oh my
gosh it's been so long hope everybody
had a good Thanksgiving my favorite
comment on Wednesday was from Jim lubke
who says
we need to fight this fight now or we
won't be able to put up much of a fight
in the 2024 race yup the folks who say
Charlie Brown needs to stop calling out
Lucy's Shenanigans and just get better
at football are missing a critical point
of course whatever you want to say about
the 2022 midterm elections
I think we have to admit that Arizona
was extremely sus it was very very
suspect and a lot of the voting machines
did not work and there were all these
dodgy practices of putting the
provisional ballots into this box at box
number three I think it was called and
the box was not checked to see how many
ballots there were before uh they went
in
and then their poll workers now who were
testifying saying that there were
hundreds more votes than registered
voters who came in and were checked in
that day and the whole thing just stinks
to high heaven and then it took a week
to count the ballots and then what do
you know the Democrats just barely eat
it out so yes the Republicans need to
win Arizona in 2024 in order to win the
presidency and so if we don't fix the
voting problems there then you could run
the greatest campaign in the world but
it doesn't really matter so much
who votes and how many people votes it
matters much more who count the who
counts the votes and in the words of FDR
to LBJ who sits on The Ballot Box you
know another important reminder
this is the last day of our best sale of
the year it is 50 off annual memberships
it ends at midnight with that I have a
thought to share last week the national
retail Federation forecast record sales
for this holiday season projecting that
over the next few weeks we will hand
over to retailers nearly one trillion
dollars of our money and what are they
going to do with the money that you and
I choose to give them
this year Walmart kicked out the my
pillow guy Mike Lindell and used our
money to force train their workers in
critical race Theory denouncing the
United States as a white supremacy
system this year Amazon used our money
in their Studios division to produce
both a castrated Lord of the Rings
series which rejects masculinity and an
anti-feminine A League of Their Own
reboot that is quote euphorically
unapologetically gay even this weekend
Disney used consumers money to release
an animated film called Strange World in
which a woke father encourages his 16
year old son to flirt with another boy
these companies ridicule ideals shame
freedom and warp a child's conscience to
everyone listening or watching right now
boycotts are not enough because boycotts
are short-term they come and go in a
week and then these soulless companies
get right back to the business of making
your morals and your way of life extinct
there is only one thing in a global
economy that can reverse the left-hand
path of multinational corporations such
as Walmart
Amazon and Disney only one thing can
tame them and that is competition we are
that competition subscribers supporting
the daily wire are that competition and
because of our subscribers we will grow
into a long-term competitor to check
Disney and their kind by creating
cultural breakthroughs by releasing
explosive documentaries by uncanceling
important voices
by developing awe-inspiring films that
celebrate industry and heroism and truth
justice in the American way by producing
instant children's Classics only then
only after Disney and their whole woke
Pals have seen the daily wire and others
out competing their content will they
reverse course or they'll die let me be
as transparent as I possibly Academy
this Cyber Monday my podcast and those
of the other daily wire hosts streaming
for free on the internet
do not generate enough ad revenue for us
to compete with Disney's 30 billion
dollar entertainment budget that's what
our subscribers do our subscribers are
concerned citizens who choose to make
long-term investments in Daily wire plus
funding both cultural wins such as the
halting of transgender surgeries on
children at Vanderbilt and content wins
as in Daily wires upcoming Blockbuster
films and documentaries we at the daily
wire
are investing everything in this to put
government big Tech and Hollywood back
on their best behavior you can join us
for less than 100 right now invest long
term in the daily wire today with 50 off
new memberships and gift memberships for
your loved ones until 11 59 and 59
seconds tonight it's easier than ever to
get great content and finance our
mission to help you and your loved ones
live more freely wow did I sell you on
that are you gonna buy a subscription
you absolutely
should
the latest Tempest in a teapot Donald
Trump is a Nazi why is Donald Trump a
Nazi well because he had dinner with
Kanye West who's a Nazi and Kanye West
brought his friends who are Nazis and
therefore Donald Trump's a Nazi that's
that's the headline okay that's what
people are telling you
what happened
well here's here's how Trump describes
it untruth social he says this past week
Kanye West called me to have dinner at
Mar-A-Lago shortly thereafter he
unexpectedly showed up with three of his
friends whom I knew nothing about we had
dinner on Tuesday evening with many
members present on the back patio the
dinner was quick and uneventful they
then left for the airport
okay sounds about right but there were
these problems because apparently Trump
brought these guys who have said all
sorts of terrible offensive things and
so therefore Trump is a Nazi right
that's what they said so then Trump goes
goes on he says
so I help a seriously troubled man who
just happens to be black yay Kanye West
who has been decimated in this business
and virtually everything else and who
has always been good to me by allowing
his request for meeting at Mar-A-Lago
alone so that I can give him some very
much needed advice he shows up with
three people two of whom I didn't know
the other a political person who I
hadn't seen in years
I told him don't run for office a total
waste of time can't win fake news went
crazy
okay but the libs aren't buying it
they're saying no Trump he's I'm not
saying the same thing they've been
saying for seven years what do you think
is more likely
two two reads on this dent
the first read is what Donald Trump said
his friend of many years who's been very
good to him who clearly has troubles and
who has just had his entire net worth
basically wiped away asked for a meeting
and Trump said okay come we'll have
dinner and I'll give you some advice
or
Trump is secretly plotting the the Nazi
takeover of the United States because he
hates Jews he hates Jews that's why his
daughter converted to Judaism that's why
his grandkids are Jewish and that's why
there's a town named after him in Israel
and that's why he he pushed the Abraham
Accords and and and which of those two
is uh more likely
obviously it's the former it's just a
complete Tempest in a teapot it's
another another ridiculous attempt to
attack Donald Trump and frankly I think
it probably helps Trump
because
Trump's biggest competitor right now on
the right is not Kanye West I don't
think I think it is probably Ron
DeSantis a lot of Trump's supporters and
former supporters have gravitated toward
Ron DeSantis and one of the arguments
for Trump over Ron DeSantis is that
Trump is the one
that they really hate Trump is the one
that the libs really want to get he's
the real threat they're Threat all of
his their Firepower at Trump and this
seems to back that up they're just still
trying to destroy Donald Trump
so I I don't think you need to you know
throw the man away and say oh my gosh
she had this dinner you're going to see
10 more of these episodes before the
year is through and don't forget we have
two years until the presidential
election speaking of the Nazis
Alyssa Milano is taking a stand
she's taking a stand against Fascism and
hate and white supremacy she's giving
back her Tesla here's what Alyssa Milano
said she said
I gave back my Tesla I bought the VW
electric vehicle I love it I'm not sure
how advertisers can buy space on Twitter
publicly traded companies products being
pushed in alignment with hate and white
supremacy does not seem to be a winning
business model
I don't know if Alyssa Milano is a huge
history buff
but uh
VW has a little bit more of assorted
history than Tesla does a VW of course
was founded by Adolf Hitler himself and
the Nazi party uh it means the people's
wagon Volkswagen
but of course she doesn't know this she
doesn't know anything
this
reminds me that people very prominent
people in public life have absolutely no
historical frame of reference or memory
okay everything is just in this
Perpetual now this Perpetual sort of uh
Mania that we're in and so people forget
forget about ancient history and
medieval history Hitler founded
Volkswagen less than 100 years ago
doesn't matter there's just this
Perpetual noun and you're seeing this
accelerate you're seeing this accelerate
in Canada
actually Justin Trudeau I referenced
this a little bit last week Justin
Trudeau is now the first world leader to
go on a drag race show
hi Queen hi I'm so sorry to interrupt I
know it's a big day but seeing as we
have the best Queens from around the
world we thought you deserved a proper
welcome please help me welcome to the
Canada's drag race work room the prime
minister of Canada Justin Trudeau
do I have to kiss his rings
are here at a summit and I think I'm a
little too late yeah unfortunately we're
actually just about to do makeover
episodes Queens anybody want to take it
on
this is groundbreaking the first ever
world leader to visit a drag race set uh
listen
I'm glad to be the first I look forward
to the time there's a third or a fourth
to have a world leader in the work room
talking to us how amazing is that you
better work Justin Trudeau yes
totally historic isn't this so historic
but then when I saw the clip I thought
wait a second
didn't Nancy Pelosi already go on one of
these shows wait a second didn't AOC
already go on one of these shows
oh but I guess neither of them are world
leaders in the sense that neither of
them are a head of state
so now Justin Trudeau he's making
history it's all it's how historical is
this Justin Trudeau is the third lib in
the last six months to go on a weird
drag queen show
but it's historic because he's the first
world leader from Canada on this special
version of the show
how many
historic firsts
do there have to be
before uh people recognize that the
alleged historical first groups have a
ton of power and dominance in our
society how many how many do we see with
it because
the way this is Being Framed is this is
so brave of Justin Trudeau no not at all
it would be brave not to go on the drag
queen show the the people who are in
power
are relentlessly pushing transgenderism
it's it would it would take some courage
to stand up against that but it's very
effective if you want to amass power one
very effective way to do it is to claim
victimhood you heard me allude to this
when we were talking about the daily
wire memberships for Cyber Monday but
you you just saw this over the weekend
with Disney Disney just had the historic
first
hold on let me see what the history it's
the historic first gay teen romance
animated film it's called strange world
it's the historic first though I thought
wait hold on how many how many times now
have I read the headline historic first
gay blank from Disney
I mean you have Disney Executives on
leaked video saying that they were
pushing a not so secret gay agenda there
have been gay kisses in this thing and
gay relationships in this thing and gave
this and gay that but I guess that
because this one's an underage gay
relationship that's the big new historic
first and it totally flopped
the the the movie brought in 4.2 million
dollars in ticket sales they're
projecting that it could make as little
as 21 million dollars over the full uh
holiday weekend
the movie was 180 million dollar budget
so it's just a complete failure so why
is that because the people don't want to
see it of course not you can be totally
open-minded and Live and Let Live and
you're not homophobic or anything at all
and you don't want to go take your kid
to see like cartoon gay teenagers
kissing right they just not something
that people want but but the
conservatives don't
unfortunately the conservatives don't
recognize the game that is being played
here and they they want to allow the the
cultural revolution to to go halfway
they don't want to totally stand against
the cultural revolution but they don't
want it to go all the way either they
want it to stop halfway if you stand in
the middle of the road though you will
in fact be hit by a truck
the the reason that
the the Disney teen gay movie failed is
because people don't want to see it
but the reason it was made in the first
place is that the entire culture has
normalized homosexuality
but the problem is if you normalize
homosexuality then you you have to
normalize it for young people too
this is where I actually think that the
left makes stronger arguments than the
right
if homosexual behavior is totally normal
totally fine no questions about it
whatsoever Christianity Judaism Islam
every
many pagans everyone who is though not
those Greeks they got a little frisky
with each other but if the vast majority
of people have ever thought about these
questions were all totally wrong and
there's no moral question whatsoever
about homosexual Behavior then
then why shouldn't it be normalized for
teenagers too
people develop romantic feelings when
they're teenagers
people go on little dates and they have
little crushes and they flirt with each
other when they're teenagers
so why why would we now be saying well
no you're only allowed to have
representations of crushes and dates and
teen romances for straight couples not
gay couples
why would we that wouldn't make any
sense
unless you were to go all the way and
say no homosexuality is abnormal and
maybe we'll be open-minded about it and
we're not going to be cruel and we're
not going to be mean we're not going to
be vicious and all these different
things but we have to acknowledge it's
abnormal it is not the norm not what
we're aiming at okay and therefore we're
not going to present it in our popular
culture we're not going to make every
single movie and every single thing gay
all the time and we're certainly not
going to present teenage teenagers in
these gay relationships in cartoons
but I don't think the conservatives are
willing to go there
I don't do you no because it feels icky
and you know that you'll be called
phobic or this or that and it it also
rubs up against
pun unintended it rubs up against
a liberal premise that that many
American conservatives have adopted
which is that politics is ultimately
just about the individual individual
Choice individual preference do whatever
you want to do as long as it doesn't
hurt me just do whatever you want to do
I have no right to come in and tell you
not to do that the state certainly has
no right to come in and tell you not to
do that
you just have a sort of radical
individual autonomy
now that is not traditionally a
conservative point of view that is a
liberal point of view okay that that is
the consequences of John Locke okay
the conservatives traditionally tend to
go a little more for the Aristotle idea
you know they tend to go a little bit
more for the idea that man is a
political being or a social being we
obviously are influenced by one another
there obviously are norms and standards
in society and there always will be and
so we need to just agree on what those
are and hopefully we have better
standards and not worse standards right
I don't the reason that I think the libs
are going to win is not because the libs
are omnipotent
or the libs are so smart or the libs
what I think the reason that the lips
right now are more likely to win on
these cultural issues is because the
conservatives
don't have any Clarity on it and they
don't they don't they don't see
they don't see how far back on the
slippery slope you gotta go
to stop this sort of stuff because it's
a pretty far ways back
and so as a result this movie is going
to bomb and you know what you're going
to get another gay teen cartoon and that
one's probably going to bomb too and
you're gonna get another gay teen
cartoon it's just going to keep going
because the libs are determined to
normalize this sort of thing and the
conservatives are not going to resist it
a very very effective way
as I mentioned to to amass power is to
claim victimhood so a lot of this uh
came out of AIDS when during the AIDS
epidemic you saw lots of gay guys dying
and this created a lot of public
sympathy rightly so and as a result of
that you saw a huge leap
in the gay gay rights movement and then
ultimately that leads to redefining
marriage and ultimately that leads to
transgenderism
but sometimes because this is an
effective political tactic
sometimes people just fake it a lot of
times people just fake it actually so
over the last month there's a gay bar in
Hell's Kitchen it's called verbs v-e-r-s
verse
and they've had four separate incidents
of an individual throwing bricks Through
the Windows
awful terrible homophobic attack right
well according to Borough president New
York
the epidemic of lgbtq plus violence is
National well-known gay bar on
Manhattan's west side has been attacked
repeatedly in recent weeks we cannot
stand for this according to a city
council member this man and they show a
picture of the guy this man has thrown
bricks at the window of verse bar four
times in recent weeks
these are hate crimes against the lgbtq
community as opposed to love crimes you
know they hate the hate ones not the
loved ones please help us identify him
if you have any information please
contact NYPD hate crimes at this address
or this number
now this was going a little too far with
the city council member because he
showed the picture it was a little bit
of a video
they found the guy
the guy is not being charged with a hate
crime
why is he not being charged for the hate
crime because he is not a homophobe how
do we know he's not a homophobe because
he is a gay guy
it was a gay guy doing it so now the
story goes away
there was that shooting at the gay club
in Colorado
the moment the shooting happened
obviously it's very sad whenever
shooting happens but the moment it
happened you had this flood from the
left-wing media
they said this is a homophobic attack
this is the result of people like those
over at the daily wire
who opposed the lgbtq agenda this is
there's a few of blood on your hands
all you evil conservatives
then what happened
turns out the shooter is a member of the
lgbtq community and the shooter
identifies as non-binary and then and
then what happened the story completely
disappeared
completely disappeared okay
it was just Jessie Smollett
Jesse this is a homophobic anti-black
attack in the south side of Chicago
which is Maga country and there were
white supremacists with nooses okay this
isn't totally checking out but they
still push the story and then when it
became clear he made the whole thing up
the story just went away
and it's important for people to
recognize this when you're reading the
news
you you have to recognize that
yes the stories are probably not being
reported accurately
so yes they spread fake news in that way
but it goes even further the only reason
you are seeing certain stories
is to push an agenda
newspapers have editors Okay the reason
that these stories end up there in the
first place the reason you've heard of
these stories is because they're pushing
an agenda
you see this in every news story forget
about the gay stuff or the race stuff or
whatever you see this with the war in
Ukraine
why is it that the war in Ukraine is the
only war that anyone's really heard
about in recent years
it's not because it's the only war going
on there are plenty of Wars going on in
Arabia in Africa in Asia there are Wars
going on all over the place
you're hearing about that war because
it more directly involves the United
States even though the U.S doesn't want
to admit it
and two because the the West feels a uh
at interest the United States feels a
national interest in that war and so
you're seeing a ton of it that's that is
why that is appearing to you and it's
why it's even in your own perception
okay
so
it helps to be able to see through these
sorts of things and and when you see
shifts in power that's especially when
it becomes clear because all of the
things that that the side that was in
power have been whining on and rattling
on about for months and months and years
and years all of a sudden when they
totally back away from them
you realize how hollow their claims were
to begin with I'll give you a concrete
example of this Adam Schiff and the
Democrats you've heard the Democrats
talking about how there are terrible
threats existential threats to our
sacred democracy and the threats are
when you question how they ring the
elections but but also
if you refuse to go along with certain
Congressional subpoenas if we if we mock
the January 6th committee that's a grave
threat to our sacred democracy until the
Republicans take charge
if you are subpoenaed by Republicans
when they take over will you comply
um you know what we'll have to consider
the validity of the subpoena but I would
certainly view my obligation
administration's obligation to follow
the law and the fact that they have
disrespected the law is not a precedent
I would hope that would be broadly
followed but we'll have to look at the
legitimacy or lack of legitimacy of what
they do
well it would depend on the legitimacy
of the subpoena
okay
it would depend on I was just told six
months ago that if Steve Bannon or
whoever of some right-winger does not go
along with some completely ridiculous
partisan committee like the January 6
committee which was all Democrats and
then two fake Republicans Liz Cheney and
Adam kinzinger who effectively are just
Democrats if if Republicans don't go
along with the Stalin show trial
that we're a terrible threat to our
sacred democracy but now the Republicans
get a bare majority in the house there
you know that their committees are going
to have to be bipartisan committees they
say hey Adam Schiff you've been pushing
a lot of this BS in in the last six
seven years are you gonna go along with
a subpoena you're a member of the House
yourself he says ah well we'll see
we'll see how it goes
okay on Friday you know we released the
first two episodes of the brand new
biblical series by Jordan B Peterson
this series is called Exodus in it
Jordan Peterson sits down with other
Scholars to read the book of Exodus and
discuss what it means and why it remains
significant thousands of years after it
was written Scholars at the table
include Dennis Prager Jonathan peggio
and many more
there will be new episodes releasing
weekly trust me you do not want to miss
it check out the trailer
in the beginning God created the heavens
and the Earth
[Music]
turns out that a book is more durable
than than Stone it's more durable than a
castle it's more durable than an Empire
you don't get away with anything and so
you might think you can bend the fabric
of reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
foreign
[Music]
God is ethic-centered not
ethnic-centered well do you want the
Pharaoh on your side or do you want God
on your side that's kind of the question
there's a profound sense here that what
is going on with the Israelites is the
contrast to Pharaoh right like under no
terms where you go and the Israel's have
to say we will go under any terms and
we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest ethical
Spirit to which we're beholden is
presented precisely as that spirit that
allies itself with the cause of Freedom
against tyranny yes exactly I want
villains to get punished but do you want
the villains to learn before they have
to pay the ultimate price that's such a
Christian question
you must be a member to watch this so
head on over to dailywire.com subscribe
to become a member and watch Exodus
today
speaking of the fight for Freedom
against tyranny Elon Musk
just had a great he just gave people a
great lesson in Practical politics my
friend Liz wheeler was reporting on the
threat that Apple and Google Play will
ban Twitter from their app stores
because Elon Musk takes over Twitter
Elon is going to let all those terrible
evil Nazis like Donald Trump back on the
platform
and therefore Apple and Google might
boot it from the App Store so Liz said
if that happens then Elon Musk has to
build his own phone doesn't he the guy
sends Rockets to Mars you know he can he
can certainly build a smartphone
Elon responds and says yup that is what
I will do
this is I certainly hope it does not
come to that
but yes if there is no other choice I
will make an alternative phone this is a
really important lesson in politics
money talks and Bs walks
a lot of times when I give speeches or
do a public appearance people will ask
me these kind of young ambitious
would-be politicos will come come up and
say Michael how do I get involved in
politics
and they never like the answer
because the answer is
if you can first make some money
make more money than you think you need
making a lot of money they say oh that
doesn't sound fun I want to go you know
I just want to run for Congress or
something no no you gotta
you got to go in with some money the
reason that Donald Trump was able to be
a bull in a china shop is because he was
a self funder
it is again one of the arguments for
Donald Trump over certain other
candidates of his opponents this time
it's not that Trump necessarily sees
everything correctly or he doesn't make
mistakes or he hires the best people or
it's not any of that
but it is that Donald Trump is much less
susceptible to outside influences
because he's got a lot of money
that's what Elon Musk is saying too
okay you think about all the
conservatives in politics in Congress in
the non-profits and they say we need to
publish a white paper on a plan on an
essay on a new book to talk about how we
need to make a smartphone to take on big
Tech or Elon Musk just comes in he
writes a check boom boom boom here you
go here's a new phone
we need here's the new plan on how we're
going to
conceptualize of a new Social Network to
build this or to maybe legislate around
Twitter and Facebook and what Elon says
okay 44 billion here we go I own Twitter
now Trump's back on
it's much simpler
okay because the problem I'm I'm not
opposed to using the government to to to
rate in some of these woke corporations
I'm all for it but the problem is the
vote corporations have a ton of money
and they've got a ton of lobbyists and
half the time they're the ones writing
the bills so it just doesn't it doesn't
really work out okay money talks and Bs
walks and this is very good news right
now
for Ron DeSantis because Elon Musk
announced over the weekend that he is
effectively endorsing Ron DeSantis in
2024. uh Elon Musk
said that if DeSantis chooses to run he
will support him good friend to have in
your corner I think you want one of the
richest men in the world in your corner
if you are running
and Ron Ron DeSantis I'm sure will
welcome that money you've seen a lot of
other big money donors who have moved
over to Ron DeSantis
but this is not without
danger for Ron DeSantis and it gets back
to my central thesis on the challenge of
the Ron DeSantis candidacy
which is that Ron desantis's sales pitch
is that he's the newer better younger
faster smarter more disciplined Donald
Trump
2.0 Trump with all the upsides none of
the downsides but
Ron desantis's role in the race in which
Donald Trump himself is running is
necessarily as the anti-trump candidate
and so Ron DeSantis is just necessarily
going to attract more centrists going to
attract more anti-trumpers going to
attack more soft liberals okay and it's
not desantis's fault he's governed in a
conservative way but that's just a fact
of his role in the race so Elon Musk
when he's talking about endorsing to
Sanders he says
as a reminder I was a significant
supporter of the Obama Biden presidency
and reluctantly voted for Biden over
Trump but freedom of speech is the
Bedrock of a strong democracy and must
take precedence my preference for the
2024 presidency is someone sensible and
Centrist I had hoped that would be the
case for the Biden Administration might
have been disappointed so far
but would you Norse DeSantis yes so if
you run DeSantis and you're running in a
primary that's not necessarily the
endorsement you want you don't
necessarily want the endorsement of a
guy who says oh I loved Obama oh yeah I
voted for Biden over Trump yeah I want
someone's Centrist I don't want a
conservative that's that's going to be
the needle that Ron DeSantis has to
thread
so right now you're seeing a huge Suite
of support I mean virtually every
conservative pundit in the country is is
endorsing Rhonda's antis at this point I
think I'm the last pundit in America the
last conservative media figure who has
said hey guys the election's two years
out I'm not endorsing someone two years
out in a primary before we have any of
the actual primary fights but the in
terms of the media
they've gone hard for DeSantis then
you're seeing this reflected in some of
the polls in Iowa right now looks like
DeSantis is up in North Carolina in New
Hampshire rather looks like to say it
this is up Florida obviously DeSantis is
up so you you
you could see the the party you died
around around Ron DeSantis but that's a
long ways app okay the the campaign has
not really begun yet and so
you're DeSantis is going to have to
constantly play this balancing game
I'm more conservative than Trump I'm to
the right of trump on the vaccines I'm
to the right of trump on the lockdowns
but I'm more Centrist and sensible than
Donald Trump so please Elon give me your
money please anti-trumpers come over and
support me that's going to be a tough
act if Ron DeSantis can can do it
he will be one of the most agile
politicians of his generation
it's a very very difficult dance
to dance that's just the way that it it
goes
those will be the challenges for the
Republic in two years we are facing lots
of challenges right now
one of the biggest challenges and no one
is talking about it is that people in
America have become loners okay the
Washington Post
stopped clock is right twice a day The
Washington Post
ran a decent column with uh with data
from the American time use survey
just looking at how many hours per week
Americans are spending alone
Americans 15 and older
are spending way more time alone than
they were in 2013. in 2013
you you see the numbers jump about 10
hours per week up until 2021 alone
the time with friends is way down four
hours per week and the time with
companions as differentiated from
friends is down about five hours per
week now part of this is obviously covid
because the government told us that we
couldn't go out and see our family or
see her friends or go to holidays or do
anything for
for two years
but covet is over
and for sensible people kovid was over
within six months
so it doesn't quite explain how in 2021
this was still a problem and what's
going on right now the the other issue
here
is that because of Technology people
feel like they are with other people
when in fact they are not
so they'll say well I'm on the social
network so I I sort of feel like I'm
with people but I'm not I'm actually
alone in my room or maybe I go on to
some
chat or stream or even a zoom call but
you're you're not really with other
people
and this gets to that same issue we were
talking about earlier in the show as to
why the conservatives are probably going
to lose on some of these cultural issues
it's because they're two distinct
Visions here okay there's the the John
Locke vision
the liberal Vision classical liberal new
liberal all the liberal Visions which is
that man is essentially an individual
then there is the traditional Vision the
conservative Vision that man is not
really ultimately an individual man is
ultimately social parent political
and the problem with that that
difference in Visions is that both the
conservatives and the Liberals very
often agree with the liberal Vision that
we're just ultimately individuals born
out of nothing floating as atoms in the
air
no obligations to anybody just do
whatever you want Define your own
identity make yourself your own God to
find your own moral order just you do
you and and it's so corrosive it's like
acid it just destroys every institution
because then marriage
family ceases to be a a network of
obligations and duties that bind people
together but it becomes just a sort of
nice companionship to augment your life
and then the moment that the marriage
turns a little sour you know you start
to get the seven year itch or something
you say oh this marriage is sort of
bothering me now these kids they're sort
of a hassle what do you do you just
dissolve the marriage
that's where you get
skyrocketing divorce it's where you get
no fault divorce
when when
marriage and family cease to be a series
of obligations and duties and normative
behaviors and it just becomes if it
feels good do it that's when you get the
complete redefinition of marriage
to say no it's no longer the union of
one man and one woman for the good of
the spouses at the sake of the
generation education of children no it's
just two people who like spending time
together you know Love Is Love or
Whatever until it's not and then you can
break up and find somebody else
it's so corrosive when when Society
ceases to be that Bond of Duties and
obligations then it's we we lose the
sense as even John Kennedy pointed out
of astronaut what your country will do
for you but what you should do for your
country
then then the country just becomes the
place where I live where I could make
some money and feel good
and as long as as long as I'm making
money and feeling good okay great the
moment I'm not whatever I'll go
someplace else the the nation's borders
dissolve the nation's people dissolve
the nation's tradition nation's Vision
the nation's animating principle it all
just dissolves okay
and you don't need to go very far to see
that
I I actually prefer spending time by
myself a lot because I just get tired I
work I travel you know I kind of like to
stay home a lot read some books have a
cigar
often I will force myself to go out
not because I necessarily want to but I
know that it's good for me okay it is
good for you to go out see people
you should go to church for lots of
reasons but it's good to go to church
also for Community it's good to go out
to a bar every now and again to see
people it's good to go out to the Public
Square it's good to go out and see a
movie it's good to go it's good to go do
stuff it's good to go to the parties
okay we've got Christmas coming up
everyone's going to start throwing
Christmas parties already because we
have total Advent Erasure and everyone
just likes to jump ahead and Mariah
Carey is going to be everywhere pretty
soon well it's you should go to those
things okay
because as Americans spend more time
alone they become more miserable they go
crazier and you get lost in your own
delusions and that's why we now have a
crazy delusional country if the price of
your Thanksgiving meal has left a bad
taste in your mouth remember it is
completely normal to keep paying more
and more for the same things right wrong
well right now the daily wire cyber week
sale is on and everything in our shop is
40 off that's right 40 off my books
reasons to vote for Democrats a
comprehensive guide that is a number one
Amazon best-selling presidentially
endorsed book president Trump says it's
a great book for your reading enjoyment
and also speechless my number one
National best-selling book with words
speechless controlling words controlling
Minds 40 off
the iconic daily wire truth bomb and our
new left of steers dog bowl remember it
is free shipping on orders over 75 bucks
and you get a free leftist tears tumbler
with orders over 100 so unless you're
one of those super fans who actually
just wants to give us extra money do not
wait go to dailywire.com shop today get
our best deals of the year on all the
gifts worth giving the reason we have to
fight against the great reset agenda of
just putting us all in our pods and we
don't see anybody and we're just
isolated we're spending all this type of
load is that when people are broken down
into this atomized individual we're all
isolated it's much easier to control us
it's much easier to transform Society we
are seeing it happen in real time I had
you a viral Tick Tock video do you think
it's good for kids to see all of these
sexualized things like people kissing
each other girls kissing each other guys
and thongs girls out yourself yes
because if you don't show them this now
then they Harbor who they are as they
get older they feel like they're not
included in society so you think
sexualized activity should begin with
them at a young age yes I mean I was
watching like eight years old and you
think that's good yeah
should the LGBT be inclusive of
bestiality
that is with animals
I mean if that's what you want then
that's what you want you to accept that
yeah
now I know that this is just an anecdote
I know this this is just one lady on
Tick Tock but the plural of anecdote is
data
and you see people making these sorts of
arguments all the time and frankly she's
got a point
she goes yeah if we're going to
if we're going to tell people that it's
cool to do all this eccentric sexual
stuff when they're adults then we've got
to normalize it when they're kids they
got to see that they got to see that
represented
and yeah maybe that maybe it seems kind
of creepy like we're sexualizing kids
and yeah maybe I'm going to advocate for
bestiality and things but you know okay
whatever Love Is Love right
this is happening
conservatives are warning that you know
by the time we get down the slippery
slope pretty soon they're going to
normalize weird child sex stuff they are
doing that that is already happening
conservatives are so good at predicting
terrible things that have already
happened
it's like pretty soon we're gonna we're
gonna start seeing the things that
already we started seeing two years ago
and I don't want to hear that this is
some crazy conspiracy theory okay
in the post Jeffrey Epstein world
I never want to hear about crazy
conspiracy theories creepypeto island is
real we know about creepypeto Island
and we know that creepypeto Island
involved some of the most prominent
wealthy powerful people on planet Earth
so I don't want to hear about it you saw
that Balenciaga ad
that bizarre Balenciaga act we covered
last week where it was little kids kind
of frowning holding up a like a
dominatrix like a s m kind of clad teddy
bear
and conservatives pointed out this is
really weird and actually one of the
Balenciaga products was was on top of a
Supreme Court case about child
pornography
and
then what happened there was an outcry
and Balenciaga pulled it down and said
we're looking into legal uh recourse
against the people who put this set
together so even now the Liberals want
to brush us under the rug but Balenciaga
itself acknowledged this is sick this is
bad we got caught but this is weird
what's going on with this child's sex
stuff
Kim Kardashian who does a lot of work
with Balenciaga she came out she said
this is really disturbing but it's
happening okay
someone gave the okay on the set someone
gave the okay on the photos someone gave
the okay
putting it on the website
we know apparently American intelligence
knew about creepypeto Island because
when
Acosta Alex Acosta not the terrible CNN
talking head but Alex Acosta who was up
for labor secretary under Trump and he
was U.S attorney before that he was U.S
attorney Prosecuting Jeffrey Epstein
when he went after Jeffrey Epstein in
his own words apparently he was told no
no forget about Epstein he belongs to
intelligence so we know that this is
happening with the ascent of lots and
lots of people
okay now
what what can we do about that this this
is again one of the arguments for Trump
I don't want it to seem like I'm just
you know Shilling for Trump or something
like that I'm I'm not I recognize the
man has lots of flaws I recognize it's
not 2016. he's a little bit older he's
going to have stronger challenges this
time I'm I really am just keeping an
open mind here and the fact that I think
I'm probably the last conservative
public figure who hasn't totally tossed
this guy under the bus makes it seem
relatively like I'm more pro-trump and I
do love the guy I mean he's the greatest
president of my lifetime
and one of one of the arguments though
for him is
he is perceived rightly I think to be
outside of the system
that there was this weird system
there's this weird political system
where no matter who gets elected we get
more immigration we get more offshoring
we get more of the weird sex stuff we
get more of our sovereignty given away
to International institutions we get
more of the same foreign policy
doesn't matter Republicans Democrats
conservatives liberals it doesn't matter
except for Trump trump actually did
different things
he changed U.S trade policy he changed
at least in the early years of his
administration
before he got shut down he changed
immigration policy he changed foreign
policy he gave you an actual different
foreign policy than you saw from Obama
Bush Clinton Bush he gave you something
different okay
and so you still get the sense
that he is not
he is not part of the system now the
same could be said for Kanye West
actually this is why I think Trump was
probably smart to take Kanye's
presidential announcement somewhat
seriously
because the Kanye West campaign
has certain aesthetic similarities to
the the Trump 2016 campaign people
thought it was a joke people didn't take
it seriously he had all sorts of
eccentrics some might say unsavory
characters around him he uh there there
are some similarities there
okay you were always waiting for the
next tweet people are looking up the
next Kanye West tweet just as they were
looking up the next Donald Trump Tweet
now I don't think
that Kanye can assemble the Trump
Coalition I just don't see how he does
that
there was a path for Trump to do that in
2016 and it was basically just to be Pat
Buchanan
the way to do it in 2016 for Trump was
to be the old right kind of Pat Buchanan
anti-bushy
added on with this huge celebrity with
this huge amount of wealth I don't know
that you see that from Kanye I think
Kanye is a little trippy in some of the
things he talks about when you hear
Kanye talk about his political program
it's not as basic As Trump build the
wall
fixed Trade Stop the stupid Wars Kanye's
is much more out there and kind of
esoterican so I just don't I don't
really see that happening
but that is the appeal
to a trump or even a Kanye the appeal is
wow this system is really sick and
broken and I don't
I don't like it I want to vote for an
alternative because I feel like I'm
being played and no matter which suit I
vote for with the red Tire the blue tie
we're getting effectively the same sorts
of things okay the argument for Trump
was that Trump wasn't really a
republican that Trump had this hostile
takeover with the Republican party and
that the relationship of trump to the
Republican party was sort of a quid pro
quo oh he helps us win an election okay
the party gives me something of an
organization but they're not the same
thing they don't really like each other
okay now speaking of quid proquos this
is a story I wanted to get to last week
uh
the uh Biden Administration is being
accused of engaging in a quid pro quo
with the Saudis that uh the the Saudi
government assassinated this guy Jamal
khashoggi who was portrayed in the west
by our propaganda media as this Intrepid
journalist standing up speaking to Ruth
power that wasn't really true he was
just a Saudi spy and a political
operative but that was the way he was
presented in the western so there's a
lot of pressure on Biden to punish
Mohammed bin Salman who's the leader of
Saudi Arabia but Biden can punish
Muhammad bin Salman because we rely on
Saudi Arabia right now to help fix the
oil prices
that means Saudi Arabia has been a long
time Ally so what happened the Biden
Administration said we are not going to
hold MBS and Saudi Arabia accountable
for the killing of Jamal khashoggi now
he's being accused of a quid pro quo
is there any quid pro quo behind that
that uh that we're being nicer to them
and they might cooperate
uh there's no good for quo I think that
the decision on on uh the immunity was a
strict legal decision by the lawyers
about him becoming a prime minister and
uh determination uh that was made by the
lawyers that was not done by policy
makers but really just a legal one as
far as their decision to cut you know we
you know you and I may disagree on that
I think that a two million cut
announcement at the time was we we did
not believe was oriented uh I think that
prices were at about 88 or 87 when they
announced that it went up to almost 100
and settled back down uh mostly because
you know when you announce a cut at 2
million what we all know is that 2
million is not going to be cut and most
countries are not going to position to
cut uh production and definitely not cut
exports so I think that where their
deliberations are not connected to the
policy making
so it's not absolutely not a quid pro
quo okay this was just we uh we were
following the law and just that's why we
can't hold this guy accountable in any
sort of way for killing this spy and
turkey and uh it has nothing to do with
the oil and nothing to do with our
long-standing we're like what are you
talking about bro this is so stupid and
nobody believes it for a second
of course it's a quid pro quo
all of politics is a quid pro quo
certainly when we're talking about
International politics
that's what it is okay we need something
from Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia needs
something from us and then you negotiate
and go and that's it
by the way this was another of the
arguments for Trump was the art of the
deal now some people will say well he
didn't get the art of the deal done
quite as well as I wanted him to and so
uh regardless of the the reality of it
I'm just saying that was the argument is
that Trump looked at politics not as
this
Pie in the Sky grandiose sort of liberal
Vision but he said nah you know look I'm
gonna fix that I'm gonna fix that ah
look we can negotiate here get off your
high horse we're just gonna talk okay
we're gonna get things done all right
and I I think that is how
the conservatives as we look ahead at
what's going to be the longest
presidential primary ever as we look at
these candidates
I think we all need to get off our high
horse a little bit
think we need to back away from the
Donald Trump is a he's a Nazi evil
terrible worst president and back away
from the Ron DeSantis is just an
establishment show he's basically just
Jeb Bush or whatever and back away from
all the other candidates who could run
and and just say look
we got some we got some good options
here
okay it's it's a good it's a good
problem to have we got some good options
here who are running for president we're
going to let this thing play out these
are all big boys and we do not put our
faith in princes okay we are not here
looking for some suit to save our
country you know in in a the sense of
in a religious sense I mean we're not
that's not we're looking for a guy to
fix stuff and put the country back on
track and it's going to be an imperfect
guy but that's what we need and so
they're tough guys they can duke it out
and then we will pick our nominee we
won't we won't pick our nominee based on
which which person the media are least
likely to call a Nazi or something we're
going to pick our nominee on a quid pro
quo who is going to give us the best
policy the the lead the country in the
best possible way until the next guy we
do it all over again now today's music
Monday
speaking of cultural matters you know
I'm A hip-hop total music Maven and so
usually we go straight to the member
block here this is where I leave all of
you Hoy polloi on YouTube we're too
cheap to Shell out a dollar for the
daily wire membership but not today it's
Cyber Monday all right so we're going to
leave this open right now
you should never miss another member
block Okay click the link in the
description for 50 off new memberships
and gift memberships for your loved ones
until 11 59 and 59 seconds tonight
and join us
uh yourself
um
get Ben Davies in here I said it that's
your heart
I can't I'm so filled with rage for
those of you who have I'm taking my
earpiece out
for those of you who have not tuned into
the member block before
as we transition into the member block
my producer Ben Davies plays a song and
this is that or the other thing but one
thing he's been doing recently he's been
playing Christmas music and I said
you don't play Christmas music
until
Christmas
because to do so to do so before
Thanksgiving is obviously ridiculous to
do so before Christmas is advent Erasure
it is not Christmas
Jesus Christ is not yet born well he is
born but we're not recognizing that as
part of the liturgical year yet you wait
until Christmas and and until Christmas
you play O come O come Emmanuel or come
that long expected Jesus and
I said when they did it again they did
it to me last week and I said Ben Davies
the next time you play Christmas music
in that transition you are fired from
this company
oh
I know it's the I know it's the Advent
season and I'm supposed to cultivate a
spirit of resignation
I'm supposed to cultivate a spirit of
charity
maybe we'll maybe I'll leave it up
to the members not to all of you Hoy
polloi out there who are contemplating
do I get a membership do I join the
creme de La Creme the inner circle of
the Michael doll show but the members if
you think
that I should Grant a reprieve and a
pardon to Ben Davies this time maybe I
will maybe
if not
Off With His Head
put my earpiece back in
so Furious oh I'm shaking I'm literally
shaking what was everybody saying today
uh let's see
Oh Come All Ye Faithful Italian
says uh O Come All Ye Faithful another
Advent song that's true okay that's the
third option let's see
unquietcenter says Davies knows that we
like Angry Knolls I know I lose my
temper like three times a year but I'm
losing it Advent Erasure is what does it
to me
okay zubi Michael drew a Christmas music
line and Ben Davies not only crossed
that line but demolished I know this is
the problem is I'm gonna look like Obama
now if I don't fire him because remember
Obama said well if uh uses certain
weapons in syrup that would be a red
line and then what happened Bashar Assad
use the weapons across the red line and
Obama did nothing so now I'm going to
look like Obama if I don't fire him
uh you let me know you let me know
members if I should fire Davies over
this I'm furious
uh Advent you don't mess with sick
Michael I know well this is the problem
you can probably hear that I'm a little
bit stuffy I went up to visit my in-laws
who went up with my wife and my two
children and we saw my sister-in-law and
her two children and the whole family
but little kids
are just Petri dishes they're Petri
dishes filled with every sickness
variants of covet that do not yet exist
or that we have not been classified and
then what the kids do is they just climb
all over you and like spit on you and
just they're drooly and it's yeah
anyway I'll try to I'll try to get
better soon
let's see
Ben deserves a part in this says barrel
of monkeys we'll see we'll see about
that
uh Elizabeth good night from South Korea
merry Christmas everybody not going to
wait Michael
hey you uh are you really in South Korea
that's very impressive
let's see part of all right A lot of
people are saying pardon Ben Davies I
don't know now so remember with a gun
says Michael don't squish you taught me
that last week fire your producer
I might I maybe I should I don't know
I'm really torn on all of this guys
keep pardon Davis okay it's starting to
Trend all right you're being too nice to
bend baby so I'm going to turn away from
that I don't want to see that there
there were also a couple uh
updates from the elections that I I
meant to get to last week and we haven't
had time but I'll give it to you the
creme de La Creme the Inner Circle here
so you know there's two still two house
races that have not yet been decided how
many days are we after the election day
right now like three weeks after the
election
but there have been some wins uh my
friend Lauren bobert has won her race in
Colorado so I really like Lauren bobert
she's a she
is a now going to be a two-term
congressman hopefully should be there a
lot longer after that but she faced this
really tough battle in uh this last
election
and the media made a huge deal of it
we're going to get Lauren bobert they
hate her guts because she's a rock
ribbed conservative and so they were
just really gunning after her and you
heard this is going to be a huge upset
and then her opponent conceded and the
story went away but we we should Spike
the football you know they the libs they
thought they had her they were so
excited that the whole thing went away
when she won but I think we should uh we
should give her a round of applause
because that was good they really went
after this woman with everything they
had and she beat them which I love okay
let's get to the song
so the song is
let you down the artist is n f
who I've never heard of uh has 8.6
million subscribers oh my gosh the video
has 225 million views
this was released five years ago okay so
NF is an American is that am I
pronouncing that right or is it
pronounced
it's NF okay
is it American rapper singer songwriter
record producer he achieved mainstream
popularity in 2017 with his album
perception which charted at number one
in the US and was certified platinum wow
man I'm so out of the culture I am so
the other day
a Sugar Ray song came on in the airport
remember Sugar Ray like I just want to
fly and I thought in my head I was like
wow this is good you know I kind of like
modern music
this song's 30 years old it's just like
oh wow yeah man I'm hip I'm cool how do
you do fellow kids all right let's play
the song
[Music]
[Laughter]
I
paradoxically that actually sort of
mitigates my Fury at Ben Davies because
you really got me is that the new Rick
Roll
I think the new the new Rick Roll is is
uh just gonna be that stupid Mariah
Carey song that people start playing in
August and then that goes through wow
really good I I listen I'm
I know this is a controversial opinion
this is probably going to be much more
controversial than anything I've said
today about Donald Trump or Kanye West
or anything like that
I kind of like the Mariah Carey sir I
kind of like it
it's happy it's bubbly it's pop
what's wrong
let's see off with a well-played them it
says Abby yeah it's pretty it's pretty
funny well played that's good that's
good look
Ben Davies says we still have a real do
we we actually do have the other song
all right let's get to the other side
it's like
[Music]
let you down all these voices
[Music]
[Music]
for you paranoia what did I do wrong
what else should I carry for you I care
for all your money
I'm proud I'm sorry that I let you down
[Music]
all these voices
[Music]
take a pause right there it's actually a
sort of fitting song for the holidays
because you know when you're a kid the
holidays are so great especially
Christmas you wake up you know the
presents it's all just perfect and but
then as you get older people start to
get sad around the holidays because
people are dead and you know you're no
longer a child anymore and so it just
becomes much much harder and you know I
don't know
your cousin your sibling got divorced
and you know this person went away and
whatever all this it just becomes uh
more haunting you know and people are
looking back and saying off only I'd
said this if only we had done this only
look how much smaller the table is this
year look at oh it's so sad and so for
for a lot of people you know this
probably does resonate so so far the
song seems a little bit indulgent to me
about daddy issues and all this sort of
thing but let's say keep going yeah
let me guess
we can so I guess I might have to leave
please don't come after me I just want
to be alone right now I don't really
want to thank it all go ahead just drink
it all you're gonna call them on like
nothing's wrong ain't that what you
always do I feel like every time I talk
to you you're in an awful mood what else
can I offer you is
right now I wish that I could say I'm
proud
[Music]
all these voices
[Music]
yeah don't talk down to me that's not
gonna work now packed all my clothes and
I moved out I don't even want to go to
your house every time I sit on that
couch I feel like you lecture me
eventually I bet that we could have made
this working probably would have figured
things out but I guess I'm a letdown but
it's cool I checked out or you want to
be friends now okay let's put my fake
face on and pretend now sit around it
talk about the good times that didn't
even happen I mean why are you laughing
must have missed that joke let me see if
I can find a reaction no but at least
you're happy just like we're only yeah
[Music]
that's a really cutting line where you
say okay yeah we had this terrible
history together but now you want to sit
and laugh about the good times that
didn't even happen and that's so true
people forget this and and I think it is
sort of a cure to Christmas time
melancholy
which is that Nostalgia is history after
a few drinks okay the good old days
we're not as good as you remember them
okay and the present is not as bad as
you might perceive it to be
and who knows about the future the
future does not exist yet
so uh
that that another reminder it actually
ties in with what we were talking about
on the show today is that
we have obligations to our family and we
don't really perceive this anymore this
is why you see the decline in people
visiting their family for Thanksgiving
you see an increase in friends giving
you ever hear that phrase oh I'm just
we're just having friendsgiving this
year and you don't see your family but
you just see the people that you already
like and as though this were some novel
you know sort of innovation wow we've
progressed so much
we've discovered that we enjoy spending
time with our chosen companions more
than with our families with whom we have
some problems yeah no way you don't say
buddy of course that's been true for all
of history for everybody but
nevertheless nevertheless you have an
obligation
in virtually all circumstances I guess
there are some exceptions obviously but
you have an obligation to see your
family you will regret it if you don't
even though you don't like your sister
and even though you know you've got some
beef with your dad or whatever
go do it you are not an island unto
yourself you
and you will derive far greater meaning
and enjoy even I suspect from the
Fulfillment of your natural obligations
to honor your father and your mother
than you will from indulging some
individual pleasure you know to sit at
home and watch a movie instead of going
to Grandma's house for Christmas Eve
keep going
all these voices
down
I'm sorry
I'm sorry
I'm so sorry no
I'm sorry that I let you down
yeah I like that well enough you know a
little sappy a little indulgent as is
most modern music but I liked it what
did the audience think
oh it looks like the comments froze up
they froze they're probably too many
people here checking it out heading on
over to the member block
let's see
did we Arun says hey my meeting was
canceled hey Aaron what's up I'm back I
ruined one of the you know real stars of
the Michael Knowles show member group uh
did we find out how to pronounce n f
yeah I'm going to continue to say
that's kind of cool
flying mine says I like the Mariah Carey
song too I do not apologize for saying
it nor do I nor do I I'd listen to
Mariah Carey all day over the Little
Drummer Boy I I cannot agree with that
Becca
there's a great version of The Little
Drummer Boy where Bing Crosby was
already kind of old and David Bowie for
some reason is singing it and it's the
two of them there and it's just really
weird and bizarre and uh fabulous
recommend that
love the song Michael did you get a cold
yeah I think I have the Alpha Sigma
Omega Lambda Kappa Epsilon variant of
kovid that's the one where you just
permanently have covid
and it's especially true if you have two
children under the age of two you just
permanently have it and so I think I
need to smoke some more cigars just
blast that smoke through my congestion
let's see
uh during Helm of Rohan says Michael no
it's an overplayed cheesy not well
written sappy stupid Romance song that
builds itself as Christmas that is true
of most modern Christmas celebrations
okay so if you're gonna get rid of that
you're gonna get rid of most of what
goes on in the Public Square okay I'm
Michael laws this is the Michael all
show we'll see you tomorrow foreign
[Music]
[Music]